this generation unlike any other
generation in history could if we choose
and the most terrible forms of poverty
it's only by raising the standard of
living in the poorer countries that we
will ever be able to increase the
educated status of women reduce
population growth decrease afforestation
by poor farmers and globally move
towards cleaner and more efficient
technologies and maybe good to give
countries grants and financial
incentives for reducing their population
in creating a sustainable economy can we
not create a single common second
language actors in developed world must
assume responsibility for a century of
dumping and use the wealth we amassed to
avert disaster actors in the developing
world let's take the long view of
economic development and should bravely
leave their economies forward in
sustainable way giving the entire world
access to we can now make very
inexpensive computers to bring internet
and consequently entirely new levels of
education to some of the most remote
countries the world to begin a global
conversation that connects us as
citizens of the world regardless of our
geographic
injuries communications an ongoing
dialogue breaks down some of the some of
the philosophical boundaries that
separate us as people in societies and
cause a lot of conflict in our world
you